hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal ein
mittagessen und zwar ein richtig leckere
nudelauflauf mit schönen bunten gemüse
was auch für kinder was ist also das
auch ist er mit und ich glaube kinder
werden total begeistert sein wenn sie
das sehen
das ganze habe ich gemacht mit einer
leckeren sahne creme die nicht zu fettig
ist und ich zeige euch jetzt zuallererst
die zutaten und das ist alles was wir
benötigen ein mal nudeln eurer wahl ich
habe hier kleine spiralen nudeln
genommen außerdem gemüsebrühe fettarme
sahne zum kochen geflügel bisschen die
habe ich in kleine stücke geschnitten
außerdem mais erbsen und rote paprika
butter mehl und einen bewussten 2
lorbeerblätter edel süßes paprikapulver
knoblauch granulat salz weißem pfeffer
und oregano und wer das ganze noch über
backen möchte der kann auch etwas gouda
käse dazu nehmen dieses rezept ist super
praktisch wenn ihr keine zeit haben oder
das ganze vorbereitet zum beispiel am
morgen und dann nach der schule oder
nach der uni einfach nach hause kommen
das in den backofen schiebt wir gehen
jetzt zuallererst nudeln und das gemüse
und die höchsten in unserer auflaufform
[Musik]
und jetzt fragt euch wahrscheinlich herr
alles rein es soll das wartet mal ab
gleich kommt nämlich der geniale trick
wir müssen minuten nämlich nicht
vorkochen und das liebe ich deswegen
gebe ich das jetzt an die seite und dann
machen wir die leckere soße unsere soße
kochen wir jetzt vor und zwar in unserem
topf dafür mache ich jetzt zuallererst
eine mehlschwitze gibt dafür die mutter
rein und lasst sie auf mittlerer stufe
schmelzen
sobald die butter geschmolzen ist gehen
unser mehr dazu und rühren kräftig um
sobald mehl und butter gut miteinander
verbunden sind geben wir die restlichen
flüssigen zutaten mit dazu also
gemüsebrühe und die fed am sahne
[Musik]
es ist wichtig dass ihr die
flüssigkeiten jetzt ganz langsam mit
dazu gibt und nicht alles auf einmal und
dabei ständig unruhen und die mittlere
stufe die reicht ja auch vollkommen aus
also geht da nicht auf höchster stufe
noch nicht denn gleich lassen wir das
erst aufkochen
[Musik]
so ihr lieben die gewürze sind jetzt
auch mit dem topf jetzt lassen wir das
ganze unter ständigem rühren einmal
aufkochen und dann ist die so ist auch
schon fertig die fertige sauce gebe ich
jetzt in unserer auflaufform und
vermischt dass alles gut miteinander
damit auch überall was drankommt und das
geniale ist einfach dass die nudeln
jetzt in der soße garen im vorgeheizten
backofen den habe ich schon auf 220 grad
eingestellt ich gebe jetzt noch ein
bisschen käse darüber damit das schön
überbacken ist geht aber auch ohne ist
auch kein problem und es riecht auch
schon unglaublich lecker muss jahr
vorweg sagen ich habe jetzt schon muss
das ganze auszulöffeln
aber die neuen müssen wir noch garen
[Musik]
und nach der backzeit ist unser leckere
auflauf fertig geschminkt unglaublich
lecker die creme ist schön sämig und
nicht so flüssig und die gemüsearten
finde ich persönlich total lecker ihr
könnt sie auch kombinieren wie ihr
möchtet champignons brokkoli möhren es
passt alles wunderbar dazu schneidet es
nur schön fallen damit die garzeit
gleich bleibt und dann könnt ihr euer
mittag oder abendessen genießen ich
freue mich wenn ihr das ganze nach macht
nicht mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf
instagram markiert zum beispiel und die
genauen mengenangaben und in der infobox
wisst ihr bereits ansonsten freue ich
mich über ein bäumchen nach oben über
ein kostenloses abo damit ja auch nichts
mehr verpasst und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal auf sheens kitchen tschüss
[Musik]